microsoft fires back at sony tower of
fantasy struggles to launch and a
long-awaited fortnite crossover has been
teased all this on today's gamespot news
according to documents filed with
brazil's national competition regulator
microsoft has claimed that sony has paid
quote blocking rights to developers to
prevent their games from being added to
xbox game pass as part of the
regulator's review of microsoft's
proposed acquisition of activision
blizzard the company alleged that sony
had quote hampered the growth of its
game past subscription service with its
business practices microsoft's response
comes shortly after sony made its own
claim about its users jumping ship to
xbox if microsoft's deal to purchase
activision blizzard and by extension the
call of duty franchise is completed
microsoft has disputed that claim and
had also previously indicated that it
would continue supporting call of duty
on playstation quote beyond the existing
agreement and into the future another
day another gentian impact-esque game
launches tower of fantasy a new gotcha
mmo rpg ran into a few launch issues
when its servers went live in specific
regions last night but worry not because
developer hotter studios has announced
that the problems have been fixed or
will be within 48 hours and players are
entitled to some freebies to make up for
the inconveniences caused by
registration failures and login errors
hota is giving out a total of 600 dark
crystals to all players who have
registered by 5 p.m pacific 8 pm eastern
today august 11. dark crystals can be
used for a variety of things but can
notably be converted into four red
nucleus to be used in tower fantasy's
premium gotcha banner hottest studios
also announced it would be giving away
more freebies to celebrate tower of
fantasy reaching the top three game
charts in 22 countries prior to the
game's global launch all players who
register prior to august 17th will
receive 10 gold nucleus which are used
for gotcha pulls for the game's standard
banner the gold nucleus reward will be
mailed to players within the next 24
hours and will need to be claimed within
14 days once the items are in a player's
inventory they don't expire tower of
fantasy which is free to play seems to
be off to a solid start login queues on
many servers were long at launch and the
game as of writing has more than 133
thousand viewers on twitch though the
game is comparable to gentian impact
familiar combat gacha systems user
interface and a similar art style tower
a fantasy sci-fi setting custom
character creator focus on multiplayer
including pvp and the addition of
vehicles help it to stand out from
mihoyo's popular gacha game tower
fantasy is available now on pc ios and
android devices and allows for
cross-platform multiplayer dragon ball
z's addition to the battle royale is
finally
kamehame happening after months of
rumors speculation and leaks epic games
has teased that the dragon ball z event
of some kind is coming to fortnight
beginning august 16th official fortnite
social media pages shared a single image
of shenron the dragon who is summoned
when all seven dragon balls are
assembled in the show hovering over the
reality tree from the current fortnight
map dragon ball z's arrival into the
battle royale has been rumored since
early july when prominent fortnight
leaker sheena br tweeted that a symbol
representing the storied anime franchise
had appeared in the game's files further
leaks indicated that multiple skins
emotes and even a new mythic weapon
could be coming as well but nothing has
been confirmed by epic games outside of
the event's start date dragon ball z
will join naruto on the list of famous
anime franchises that have made the
shonen jump to the popular battle royale
with naruto's second wave of skins
dropping into the shop in late june
[Music]
and that is it for today's gamespot news
are you excited by dragon ball z content
in fortnite are you going to check out
tower of fantasy let us know in the
comments below and we'll see you here
tomorrow for more news on gamespot